this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
even in the best of times many of us can
forget to prioritize our mental health
that's why we wholeheartedly recommend
betterhelp
it's an online therapeutic resource that
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
counselor all from the comfort of your
home
to get started head to
betterhelp.comtvsins
you also get 10 off your first month
when you click the link in the
description
episode title indicates that fun is an
acronym but really they just sing a
bunch of [ __ ] up nonsense later that
randomly starts with these letters and
sometimes even doesn't wait
nonsense is an acronym for fun you see
how easy that was
ah lunchtime etsy krusty klab i could
keep sending narration but let's just
send this literal interpretation of the
french new wave
instead also i get he's mr krabs and he
wants his restaurant to be a fun play on
words
but did anyone think what a krusty crab
would even be is that appetizing to
anyone does anyone want their crabs to
be crusty and if so what is
wrong with you everyone enjoying their
flabby patties everyone
everyone what about this guy is he not
part of everyone
lights go out but you can see where
everyone is because their eyes are wide
open and glow for some reason in a
cartoon cliche
why does spongebob need a hair net how's
plankton even doing this
did he steal a crappy patty and install
this laser in it did he hide himself
inside
the krabby patty how is the krabby patty
even defying gravity later we see he's
got it on some sort of go-go gadget
backpack so why isn't that here and if
he can move faster by rolling why isn't
he running right now
what is this some sort of cartoon no
no so does the bucket lead to the sewer
how does that even work
and why do you need a sewer underwater
better hope your diet isn't too high in
fiber because you don't want that [ __ ]
to float
[Music]
love it first flight these are terrible
choices for your magic shop signed cards
the ace makes sense but the three of
diamonds the five of hearts at least
through the three of hearts is an odd
dependent teller
groucho marx in your krabby patty and
after all these years i thought i was
the master of torture
no way plankton that has been and always
will be caillou
i bet if he had just one friend he
wouldn't be such a meanie
missionary dating i want you to come out
and play with me spongebob might have
good intentions but could he not have
waited till after the chum bucket was
closed he's interfering
whatever
not
is just available take the krabby patty
are we all just buying into the getting
hold of a crabby patty would be that
difficult
can't you just buy one it's not about
winning
it's about fun trophy culture u is for
you and me
thinking u starts with a u and that
anywhere and any time start with an n
n is for no survivors
singing about murder wait i don't
understand this
i feel all tingly inside should we stop
title of my sex tape well i like it
let's do it again geez this fun musical
number really does go on for all the fun
time we've only got 11 minutes to tell
this story people
why does plankton even have a changing
station when he's been absolutely
stitchless this entire time
also are those supposed to be plankton's
shirt and tie he's the size of a pickle
and not a big one this equation has too
many factors and missing pieces to be
useful
i sure like sequels no one i repeat no
one
likes sequels sponge liar fire pants if
you have this much independent cheek
control you've missed your calling of
doing professional twerk work and the
twerking industry is hurting right now
so your selfishness is abhorrent
getting to third base at the movie
theater no friendship can withstand
the allure of a krabby patty it's true
i've seen many
friendships and because of krabby
patties having one of your jelly beans
move and still choosing to try to eat it
are we having fun yet
thanks again to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video people often
forget that mental health is just as
important as physical health i know i do
if you're feeling like you need to speak
to someone or you just need a mental
health check-in betterhelp is an amazing
online resource that allows you to do
just that connect with a counselor in a
safe and secure online environment and
know this
isn't self-help this is a real
connection with an actual human being
and you don't even have to leave the
house to do it it takes about as much
effort as watching a youtube video to
start your connection to better help and
hey we can all watch youtube right
i mean you're all the way at the end of
this video once you get started you can
send messages to your counselor anytime
check out information that's relevant to
your needs and book your next
appointment all on the same page
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed head to
betterhelp.com tvsens to answer a few
questions or get paired up with a
counselor within
24 hours get a whole 10 percent off your
first month by clicking that link
join over one million people taking
charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp h-e-l-p dot com
slash tv sins wow a magic shop
are you a magician trying to slide hand
with my money i'll cut you through
one time at band camp we weren't
supposed to have pillow fights
and after all these years i thought i
was the master of torture i want to play
a game
your computer has been infected with a
pornographic virus
i said you're a loser
listen up people paid good money to see
this movie
when they go out to a theater they want
cold sodas hot popcorn
and no monsters in the projection booth
i
can't believe this do not compare me to
my father i didn't compare you damn i
said you were acting like him
you're exactly like your mother
everything you're complaining about her
you're doing
you're suffocating henry first of all i
i love my mother she was a wonderful
mother just repeating what you told me
secondly how dare you compare my
mothering to my mother